I'm sure we all want to live a vibrant
and healthy life we do so many things to
achieve that from eating right to
exercising drinking plenty of water
looking after our skin and more the
reality is with our demanding hectic and
stressful lifestyle
sometimes our well-being still gets
affected what if I were to tell you you
can have more energy perform better and
boost your immune system just by adding
a few smart supplements into your diet
I'm here at Summa Pharmacy located in
someways city Kuala Lumpur to show you
the basic supplements we can start with
for better health let's start with a
supplement we're all familiar with fish
oil inflammation in our body is often
the root of all diseases omega-3 fatty
acids in fish oil helps reduce
inflammation and promotes healthy cell
growth this means less joint pain
quicker healing and maintain flexibility
omega-3 is often linked to cholesterol
as well so consuming Omega threes can
help lower levels of LDL and increase
levels of HDL the good cholesterol that
keeps our arteries clean our gut is also
known as our second brain the health of
our gut directly affects our immune
system and this can determine your mood
appetite sleep quality and even sex
drive having poor gut health can be a
result of having a bad diet stress
depression overconsumption of alcohol
and more
that's where probiotics can help
probiotics are beneficial bacteria that
promote a healthy gut supports the
body's ability to absorb nutrients and
protect your immune system next is my
current favorite collagen when you think
about collagen the first thing that
comes to your mind is that oh this is
only for those who want to look young
and beautiful well who doesn't but the
truth is that's not all collagen is
formed the reason that college
supplements are popular or maybe even
essential is because our body becomes
less efficient in collagen production
especially after the age of 13 we might
experience saggy skin wrinkles join eggs
because collagen production begins to
decrease as early as our mid 20s
hence daily consumption of collagen can
improve our skin health maintain our
youthfulness relieve joint pains prevent
bone loss build muscle mass and even
reduce cellulite multigrain drinks can
be a great supplement to have as part of
your breakfast to give your body a great
boost in fiber and other micronutrients
it can also be consumed as a pre or
post-workout drink when choosing a
product it is very important for you to
flip and read the ingredients list you
want to choose a product which contains
a variety of whole grains and avoid
those with refined grains or with sugar
listed as the first three ingredients
these are the top smart supplements to
consume daily so that you can start each
day knowing you have given your body the
essential support it needs if at all
you're lost or confused
be sure to approach your pharmacist
because I'm sure they'll be more than
happy to help you to choose the right
supplements according to your current
health and lifestyle
for more information on some way
pharmacy do visit their website and
Facebook page
[Music]